voilà pour cet entretien avec charles
berling signé johanna soudry bonsoir
valérie rebond soit on va parler
d'environnement avec vous la chronique
de l'environnement on parle de bio vous
nous disiez tout à l'heure oui et de
filière céréalière puisque selon une
dernière étude de passion céréales l'île
de france est la première région minière
avec 16 % de la production nationale de
farine cette filière compte trente-deux
mille emplois alors avec nous sur ce
plateau pour en parler olivier de seine
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes directeur des
moulins de bras seuil à offranville près
de mantes la jolie et vous pouvez tout
d'abord nous nous parler des grandes
spécificités de ces moulins des moulins
en ile-de-france effectivement c'est la
plus grande région meunière d'île de
france pourquoi parce que à paris il y
avait beaucoup d'habitants donc il faut
aller nourrir beaucoup de personnes et
donc les moulins se sont installés dans
la région parisienne et en plus on était
à proximité des champs de blé parce
qu'il ya autour de paris et autour de la
delà de la banlieue de la grande
banlieue elle ya des chemins il y a des
terrains il y à des champs de blé et
donc de quoi donner du grain à moudre au
moulin alors justement sur ces images
qui sont actuellement diffusées on voit
ce qu'on a pu tourner au sein d'eads et
mouna de brassaï dont vous êtes le
directeur alors parlez nous un petit peu
de décès moulin qui sont qui sont
particuliers alors ne le moulin de
passeurs effectivement est un moulin
particulier par rapport aux mots
l'ensemble des modes des moulins
français parce qu'on a deux spécialités
une spécialité et d'écraser sur des
meules en pierre et exclusivement sur
des modes en pierre ce qui donne à la
farine un côté plus coûteux le la
présence du germe de blé est donc un pro
un pain qui va être fait par les
boulangers avec une un peu différent d
un peu différent de l'ap de la baguette
courante la deuxième société
spécificités et c est dû aussi à la
région c'est que l'on à des crasses des
céréales biologiques et plus de 50% nos
céréales biologiques viennent
d'ile-de-france et autour du moulin pour
une grosse majorité à 15 ou 20 km autour
du moulin jeudi filière bio que l'on a
mises en place au cours des années alors
vous êtes précurseur en la matière
qu'est ce que les moulins de bras seuil
on commençait le bio en 1972 celle
historique de bras seuil c'est sa force
c'est effectivement le bio n'est pas une
mode dues à l'environnement actuel et à
toutes là toute la démarche c'est que
sais-tu s'est ancré dans les gènes c'est
ancré dans les entrailles du moulin on
est producteur de farine bio depuis donc
1972 et on a ce qu'on a pu changer par
rapport à mai à 72 c'est que maintenant
le blé on va le chercher à côté de chez
nous parce qu'on a initié ses côtés
intéressant jaillir de notre de notre
présence au milieu de la filière blé
farine pain c'est qu'en fait on a eu ni
si des agriculteurs on les incite à
passer en bio à travailler un petit peu
différemment et donc de pouvoir nous
fournir et pouvoir après fournir des
boulangers en région parisienne
principalement parce que vous
votre vos céréales blé viennent
principalement de 50 pour 50% de daisy
feeling tout à fait 50% des yvelines on
a à peu près une quinzaine de pourcents
d'île de france parce qu'il faut
imaginer effectivement quand sur sur
l'île de france et après il ya près de
la moitié en fait des terres qui sont
des terres agricoles donc et on a un
bassin de céréales important on a aussi
la chance d'être traversés par la scène
et donc de pouvoir exporter no no no no
céréales gerber les pays étrangers et
c'est une des forges à dire de
l'agroalimentaire français 1 c'est
d'avoir cette exportation est donc une
balance commerciale plutôt excédentaires
donc c'est encore un bon point pour
l'industrie agroalimentaire on avait
quelques images à l'antenne tout à
l'heure de cette farine bio c'est quoi
de la farine bio c'est quoi la
différence avec lui notre farine plus
traditionnelle alors la farine bio la
différence dans la farine bio la farine
traditionnelle en fait la farine bio ces
tissus de blé qui sont cultivés d'une
façon biologique c'est à dire sans aucun
apport de produits chimiques de
fongicides pesticides et c'est
travailler comme ont travaillé avant
qu'il n'existe ces produits qui
permettent de favoriser jédir la la la
la culture de la culture du blé est donc
bio c'est jédir naturel y a rien dedans
et quand vous avez commencé à faire du
bio c'était dans les années 70 c'est ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure tout le
monde faisait du bio dans la farine à
8,72 on comment on avait quand même
alors il ya toujours eu du bio et bien
habillés comme il y avait toujours eu
des moulins à me avec des meules de
pierre parce que avant qui la révolution
industrielle on n'avait que des meules
en pierre donc aujourd'hui on a on est
revenu sur des sur des moulins plus
moderne avec des capacités beaucoup plus
importante et des farines que l'on
voulait un peu plus blanche pour faire
la baguette française l'emblème de notre
de notre pays donc à aujourd'hui le bio
on l'a remis au goût du jour parce que
par oppose par non pas par opposition
mais pour pour pouvoir permettre de
donner aux consommateurs un choix entre
une grosse culture avec des rendements
importants donc le blé classique si on
n'avait pas de gros rendement on ne
pourrait pas nourrir les français donc
et on veut pas mettre en opposition les
deux cultures ces deux types de culture
complètement différentes mais avec une
un plaisir jédir canton à moi j'ai
assisté à la mise en place de bio dans
des fermes où on a vraiment de
l'adducteur qui ont le plaisir de
retrouver le goût de la terre le travail
la présence sur le sur le terrain parce
qu'il faut suivre la terre l'écouté plus
attentivement mythe mans c'est plus cher
pour le consommateur alors
économiquement c'est effectivement un
peu plus cher mais pour le pain c'est un
des produits les moins chers en bio
pourquoi parce que l'on que nous dans un
moulin que l'on écrase le blé biologique
ou du blé conventionnel c'est le même
c'est le même rapport en fait donc
finalement à la fin à la fin au bout du
compte le pain bio c'est par rapport à
une baguette conventionnelle c'est à peu
près 15 aventure sont plus chères cépage
et du bio manger du pain voilà c'est
moins cher nous a tous touchés par les
pins et en plus il faut manger du pain
d'épicés très bon
veniez de père en fils expliquez-nous un
petit peu le votre arrivée dans ce dans
ce moulin et et votre histoire
antérieure bah c'est comme comme bon
nombre de moulins de meunier bon moi
j'ai effectivement je suis né dans le
moulin de j'ai passé mais après midi
mais mercredi les les jeudis à l'époque
a joué dans le moulin à porter h à
porter des sacs et tout doucement mais
c'est une c'est un vrai plaisir c'est un
métier passion parce qu'on en fait on a
on transforme un grain de blé en farine
et c'est magique alors c'est ce même si
c'est hyper classique sur les bleus vous
l'avez vu dans le reportage on sait ça
reste très très très traditionnelle mais
on a énormément évolué sur une garantie
de sécurité alimentaire parfaite des
normes de qualité des réglementations
qui font qu'aujourd'hui on est on est on
est bon on a des produits qui sont sains
et le pain c'est quoi c'est de l'eau de
la farine de la levure et du sel encore
il faut en consommer les moulins
d'aujourd'hui du 21ème siècle ne
fonctionne plus du tout comme nos
moulins d'antan on va le voir on a
réalisé effectivement avec une équipe un
reportage au sein des moulins de brassaï
je vous propose de regarder tout ceci en
images
jadis à offranville les moulins de bras
seuil et tao et si la rivière est
immuable les moulins eux ont évolué mais
dans cette profession exercée de père en
fils la tradition demeure malgré la
modernisation
précurseur de la filière bio depuis 1972
c'est le seul site des yvelines à
posséder un moulin à meule en pierre et
assignant revient vers le côté nature
qui a été un petit peu décrié un peu
chahuté dans les années précédentes et
qui aujourd'hui prend son prend sa vraie
existence on sa vraie valeur en ayant
des produits naturels les produits tracé
des produits de la région ce en quoi
nous on croit depuis des années a
aujourd'hui ben on est content que ça se
lit de france on revoit 7 cette force
c'est une vraie force du monde brassait
exemple d'engrais et de produits
chimiques
les farines bio conservent toutes leurs
qualités nutritionnelles
blé seigle et pauvre petit et notre un
rassemblement les farines sont écrasés
broyé et renvoyé d'un bout à l'autre des
conduits
contrôle qualité vérification suivi des
dossiers le métier de meunier aussi
s'est adapté aux temps modernes
je dirais que le métier il a un petit
peu évolué parce que en tant que
responsable de production avance est
essentiellement être beaucoup beaucoup
sur le terrain alors que celle l'est
toujours mais parallèlement il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de travail en amont
liés à la qualité au matériel ou à la
maintenance donc c'est beaucoup plus
complet je pense qu'avant c'était il ya
plusieurs années en arrière c'était
surtout beaucoup plus technique le bio
exige de la transparence et une
traçabilité les échanges avec les
laboratoires pour analyser les qualités
des produits sont légion une exigence
qui engendre un chiffre d'affaires de 3
mille quatre cent cinquante mille euros
en évolution malgré la crise car la part
du bio augmente d'année en année une
offre qui répond à une demande
croissante en 2011 les moulins de bras
seuil ont produit 5258 tonnes de farine
alors à terme vous souhaitez ne faire
que de la farine exclusivement bio c'est
votre projet oui c'est un
c'est un des buts on se disant
effectivement qu'on a cette cette
antériorité 7 s'est-il cette image et
pourquoi pas j'allais dire de
à augmenter gr avoir un volume de plus
en plus important sur le bio est d'avoir
de plus en plus d'agriculteurs qui vont
pouvoir nous fournir ou des coopératives
qui vont nous fournir du bio et de
pouvoir vraiment avoir un moulin
spécialisé en bio et en bio en ile de
france à qui sont destinés aux farines
alors nos farine sont principalement la
boulangerie la boulangerie artisanale
mais aussi des boulangeries peut-être un
peu plus un peu plus importantes qui
sont ou spécialisés 100% 100% bio ou des
boulangers qui vont fournir des écoles
des hôpitaux donc là tout ce qui va être
la restauration collective on travaille
aussi avec certains meunier parce qu'on
a une intériorité encore une fois sur la
bio et sur la meule et donc on travaille
avec certains de nos que certains de nos
collègues un petit peu d'export
notamment dans les pays asiatiques en
angleterre parce que l'image encore une
fois ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure sur l'image du pain français
pour faire du la baguette française il
faut des farines française et des blés
français alors shekels boulanger ici à
saint quentin en yvelines peut-on
trouver vos farine dans dans le pain bio
alors j'en ai tout de suite 4 qui
viennent à mon esprit donc la fenêtre
qui se trouve donc à montigny montini
situer rapidement les marques ce que
vous en avez cité une alors allez-y la
fouettent je vais dire roydor à sa
frappe de marque comme ça pour les
concurrents
allez-y un troisième ça me semble en
aura trois ray mal et je puis dire
amour pas la boulangerie ouverte et puis
le dernier les essarts le roi mais selon
déjà c'était une marque comme ça voilà
on tapera pas sur les doigts donc une
dernière information donc pour trouver
ces bonnes saveurs en ile-de-france deux
des talents d'île de france il y à cette
marque saveurs vous pouvez nous en
parler la marque saveurs paris
ile-de-france en fait c'est une marque
qui est destiné au grand public et qui
ne va pas forcément être que sur le pain
mais surtout les produits
agroalimentaires d'île de france un
exemple alors encore la pomme de la
pomme de poissy l'amande de
milly-la-forêt le brie de meaux les la
baguette bio 2
monsieur untel qui seront des produits
du terroir ile de france eh bien merci
beaucoup pour tout ces précisions merci
valérie lartigue aux chroniques de
l'environnement la semaine prochaine au
même horaire merci encore à vous on
change complètement de sujet on va
parler solidarité à présent avec une
entreprise